and many times Hollywood does work with
the Pentagon when it comes to scripting
narratives we have seen time and time
again something happens in Iraq and
they're like okay what can we say
actually happened what really happened
those are two completely different
things how can we use this event and
change it for the best PR purposes we
saw that with Jessica Lynch we saw that
with Mainline Hollywood directors and
producers getting involved and saying
you know what this story of of the
Iraqis taking her to a hospital and
trying to help her does it really fit
our narrative let's send in the tanks
and let's say that they were holding her
hostage again they made so much things
up when it came to to war they make so
much things up when it comes to just our
everyday life everything from them
should be seen as fake nothing should be
believed by government or the
authorities until we actually have some
real life evidence that we could back up
their statements on because they are
pathological Liars satanic individuals
some of them that do awful things that
we can't even imagine how terrible they
are